monsieur le Président je
vous remercie ces premières pistes de de
d'évolution vous le dites le système est
aujourd'hui
à bout de souffle il est complexe je
crois que autour de la table on
s'accorde tous
elle pensait vous avez envisagé un
certain nombre de scénarios moi ma
question était était la suivante on est
aujourd'hui on a le gouvernement qui est
une volonté d'entrer dans une relation
transactionnelle avec les collectivités
territoriales voire même dans
personnaliser les relations avec l'État
notamment le ministre de l'Économie a
été très clair le 14 septembre dernier
en indiquant qu'il y a des collectivités
qui sont bien gérées et d'autres qui
pourront ne pas se prévaloir de l'aide
de l'État donc par le PLF qui arrive le
gouvernement accélère la mise sous
tutelle budgétaire des collectivités
territoriales les obligeants à devoir
négocier à l'avenir
chaque ligne budgétaire donc dans les
scénarios de financement que vous vous
présentez il y a des évolutions qui me
paraissent pertinentes ma question
serait plutôt la suivante est-ce que
aujourd'hui au regard des propos que
qu'indiquent le ministre de l'Économie
est-ce qu'il y a pas un scénario un
scénario
alternatif un peu plus un peu plus
globale peut-être plus innovant qui sur
lequel vous auriez pu
évoluer et proposer est-ce qu'il est pas
temps de d'engager une réflexion sur sur
une réforme globale du financement des
collectivités locales